and tonight those mean tweets from
president trump they're looking pretty
good right about now president trump he
worked around the clock might not like
his style but he did advance america's
interests at home america first he also
did it abroad he fought hard he kept his
promises and america and the world
prospered and by the way people feared
donald trump as president they believed
it when he said he would obliterate them
like he did the caliphate like he did
solomoni like he did baghdadian
associates and the al-qaeda leader in
yemen joe biden nobody believes him and
nobody thinks he even know they he even
knows what day of the week it is and now
he's being rolled by his radical
socialist party and they call all the
shots he answers to them he does what
they say if they get their way america
will never be the same again here with
more former secretary of state mike
pompeo you know i'm i'm watching the
attacks come in and they say this is the
trump plan i've asked you this question
before the trump plan correct me if i'm
wrong was predicated first and foremost
on obliterating the taliban donald trump
said to the head of the taliban
if we get an agreement and you don't
abide by it i'll let you finish the
conversation
sean it's good to be with you we we
certainly said that and then we executed
when the taliban behaved in ways that
were inconsistent with protecting
america our interests in afghanistan or
elsewhere we crushed him we used
american power to make sure that our
model of deterrence would work we we had
a real plan on how to get our troops
down to the lowest levels possible we
knew that there were certain set of
conditions that had to be met we we were
working diligently to achieve them we
went from 15 000 to about 27 2800 and we
kept order we didn't have a single
american attacked from february of 2020
on that was not because of a piece of
paper or an agreement but because they
feared our administration
i've known you for many many years i've
known donald trump well over 25 years
i know i can say unequivocally
i don't see any scenario that you would
ever abandon americans behind enemy
lines
would would that have ever happened with
donald trump as president and you as
secretary of state
no sir it's unimaginable sean that we
would have permitted this to happen we
were serious about protecting americans
not only our soldiers sailors airmen and
marines but our diplomats our
intelligence officers and all the other
americans who were there as well we made
real commitments to them we said this is
how we're going to do this in an orderly
way we proceeded across that plan they
came in and ripped it up president biden
set a political deadline an arbitrary
deadline deadline and he did so with his
military leaders having told him if you
go below 2500 or 2 700 that a calamity
will ensue he made that choice it was
deeply political and now america is
paying the price for this and donald
trump would have kept bagramer base
donald trump agree told me when i
interviewed him that he would in fact
keep would have kept 2500 uh troops on
the ground as the generals now
clearly recommended and joe biden lied
to george stephanopoulos but he also
lied saying you wouldn't abandon
americans do you
see any scenario that is relatively safe
where we can get
our people home safely because joe biden
says we have all the leverage i don't
see it
yeah sean we gave up all our leverage
when we when we ran out when we
abandoned and when we created this
debacle we not only gave up our leverage
but 13 american lives as well there are
lots of americans who are working to
help get their fellow comrades home from
behind enemy lines i hear from folks
nearly every day i'm trying to help as i
can as well we are fighting our own
government we are we are working to try
and work around and get assistance from
our government not not uh not uh we
shouldn't have to be fighting them in
the way we are i don't see this
administration beginning to change that
policy i think they want to write this
off and just turn the page that the
american people aren't going to let that
happen we'll all remember well he used
that exact phrase at the u.n uh he has
not mentioned the people that he
abandoned in afghanistan or the islamic
emirates of afghanistan in 30 days
hasn't talked about him one time tony
blinken now this is recently there there
are american groups i don't know who
they are but i understand that we have
retired
uh special ops forces retired navy seals
and generous americans that have
chartered airplanes and that are working
diligently to get americans home i don't
i want every american home i want every
green car to hold her home i want their
families home our allies that we promise
to get the hell out of there here's my
question tony blinken you had his job
is now saying that you can't take the
charter plane even if it has americans
on it you can't land in the u.s and if
you do get a third-party country to
accept your charter and they need our
approval it will not be forthcoming
now can you give me any rational
explanation for that policy because that
makes zero sense to me
no sean it makes no sense that's what i
was referencing earlier we have our own
government opposing private citizens who
are trying to help americans get home
this is this is crazy it there's there's
no rationale for this if we've got a
plane and we've got a flight we've got
people who are willing to to take their
own lives in their hands to help risk to
take that risk to get their friends and
their comrades and their fellow
americans home the state department the
department of homeland security cbp
should be encouraging that president
biden should be calling them and
thanking them not telling them you can't
land an aircraft or you can't bring a
plane to a third country there are lots
of countries who are prepared to assist
us help us get these folks first to
their country and then ultimately onward
to their final destination and our our
government's opposing that today it is
it is
unexplainable to me sean
mr secretary i say this as a friend of
yours for a lot of years um
it's great to hear from an adult on an
important national security topic
because it wouldn't have happened on
your watch thank you for being with us
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else